معسكر ليموني رسميا هو القاعده العسكريه
الدائمه والوحيده التي تديرها القوات
الامريكيه في افريقيا
جغرافيا هي اقرب قاعده امريكيه في المنطقه
للاحداث في السودان وهي تقع في دوله
جيبوتي
القاعده تضم وحدات من القوات الخاصه
والبحريه والطيران ويصل عدد القوات فيها
الى 4000 جندي في الاوقات العاديه تستغل
لحمايه الملاحه البحريه في باب المندب وفي
استهداف الجماعات الارهابيه في القرن
الافريقي اضافه الى تدريب الجنود التابعين
لدول افريقيه مختلفه
معسكر لمونيا يحتوي على مطار عسكري قد
يكون هو المحور الاساسيه في اي عمليه
اخلاء محتمله للسفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم
انس نماسي العربيه
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص الصناع على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات